j'accueille eric hamdi
ouais
excusez sont un peu timides quoi c'est
leur première télé comment ça va les
enfants la vie ça me fait bizarre alors
qu'elle est envisagée n'est pas la
télévision
c'est carrément ardisson quoi ouais
c'est bizarre mais aujourd'hui le mien a
dit al akwaa
c'est son affaire parce que comme on se
connaît quand même depuis quelques
années je sais qu'il commence à me
tourner avec vous on va en faire la
promo direct il paie puis après on verra
ce qui se passe d'accord bien entendu
d'accord à l'envié
d'accord d'accord d'asie j'y vais là
haut les baskets
la sortie au pull merde j'ai pas compris
oui c'est très joli bien sans quand vous
bougez un gentilhomme nous pourrait
causer un pardon pour moi la série
quand on fera le bourgeois gentilhomme
faudra qu'on mettre des trucs comme ça
apparemment j'ai créé les costumes sur
le site de sens que s'ils ne s'étaient
laissés seuls bien je crois dire quelle
émission qu'on a fait le plus de toute
notre musique berbère
j'espère bien celle-là et fogiel
voilà on va y aller un jour non ça fait
dix ans qu'on vient là c'est pas bien
ici
non très bien donc vous sortez votre
spectacle en dvd ça te rappelle eric et
ramzy ses mises en scène par michel
hazanavicius son vrai nom hazanavicius
est fou c'est incroyable c'est 100%
inédit 100 % des cas les voilà avec des
cannes présenté il ya des bonus donc
avec quatre sketches inédits les
coulisses les séances de travail et ça
vaut même pas 20 euros
c'est incroyable magicien là-dedans voix
de boulogne n'a rien a dit marc ça vaut
19 euros 99 et les 1 centime il faut les
laisser aux vendeurs ouais ah oui
d'accord et la moitié est reversée à une
association juste pour se marrer c'est
aussi aider l'afrique à des chinois et
chinois et des américains bétail on
donne 19 euros à la fin c'est sympa on a
le coeur sur la main que vous voulez
vous dise vous fait passer avec votre
nous on donne nos d'anodin on peut quand
tu es là comment je vous avais dit de
lui sa première paire vous aime beaucoup
ah c'est vrai en plus c'est vrai en plus
c'est vrai en plus et alors il est
génial sent trahi son modèle c'est
horrible c'est moi qui habite comme un
lord anglais malawi ouest voit quand
même que des rumeurs
mais quand il va au marché voir ses
potes et ben il a la classe deux heures
que j'attends a versé incroyable
incroyable pour ma première télé donc à
beaucoup de dvd cochard en ce moment à
comme avant pas non il est pas mal cette
petite brune
enfin bon moi mais lille nous a quittés
elle est décédée c'est vrai non
allez-vous c'est pareil à des partis
chez cauet tiako i mate ou piqué même
mais lille n'est pas ce qu'on fait c'est
un vrai on se barre jean ya beaucoup de
belleville qui sortent en ce moment
qu'est ce que vous pourriez nous dire
pour nous convaincre d'acheter votre dvd
et pas celui de djamel pas celui de
gamme
pourquoi n'en sont très bien non c'est
autre chose on fait qu'on fait quelque
chose de différent on a de la chance
d'avoir plein de dvd marrant qui sortent
en même temps toutes les acheter que
l'on voit chez kr est le vôtre
moi je sais pour l'avoir parce que moi
je suis venu les voir que notre ami
pierre palmade et je leur ai dit je
crois que j'ai bien résumé je leur ai
dit vous êtes pile à côté si tu vois
pile dedans tu vois que tu es là c'est
vachement dit la cour
ils sont pile à goûter et c'est un vrai
régal c'est vrai ça comme un compliment
negro selon les goûts
eager s'est vraiment illégal
c'est parfaitement non sensique leur
spectacle est très original c'est
absurde et pas c'est pas comparable avec
ce que fait déjà mais loue ce que fait
gaffe toujours c'est génial ce qu'ils
font mais c'est différent nous c'est pas
ancrée sur une base sociale ou rien du
tout c'est juste du vent série reste
rien à la fin du spectacle
on sait juste ma série américaine the
pursuit excuse moi il s'est re série
oui